auch in den letzten tagen und wir sehen
natürlich dann auch in der folge auf den
intensivstationen in den krankenhäusern
bei den todeszahlen wieder traurig hohe
werte es ist zehn nach zwölf und auch
wenn wir sehen dass die lage in
deutschland unterschiedlich ist dass es
in den unterschiedlichen regionen wenn
sie nach schleswig-holstein schauen oder
nach bayern noch unterschiedlichem
infektionsgeschehen mehrbelastung der
krankenhäuser ist ist doch genauso klar
wir sind in einer nationalen notlage die
auch eine gemeinsame nationale
kraftanstrengung braucht das braucht
auch
gemeinsame staatliches entschlossenes
handeln um diese dynamik zu brechen die
werkzeuge dazu sind da impfen testen aha
regeln schutzmasken oder eben vor allem
auch kontakt reduzierung dafür war der
gestrige tag wichtig neben der
entscheidung im deutschen bundestag vor
allem auch das treffen von bund und
ländern die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
sie wissen ich hätte sie mir auch schon
drei wochen früher gewünscht und drei
wochen früher auch einen unterschied zu
machen aber nun ist es gut dass sie
stattgefunden hat die wahrheit ist
alleine mit impfen mit postern werden
wir das brechen der welle dass wir jetzt
kurzfristig brauchen nicht mehr
erreichen es braucht also maßnahmen der
kontakt beschränken und dafür haben wir
uns gestern auf ein regelwerk einigen
können dass eben ab einer bestimmten aus
vitalisierung city dance also bei einer
bestimmten belastungssituation im
jeweiligen bundesland zweig in einem
nächsten schritt zweig plus in einem
weiteren schritt zusätzliche maßnahmen
der kontakt beschränkung greifen sollen
aus meiner sicht auch greifen müssen es
geht dabei vor allem auch um einen lock
down für ungeimpfte in einem ersten
schritt also deutliche kontakt
beschränkungen dort für ein solches
regelwerk das über 3g als grund maßnahme
für herbst und winter hinaus es klare
kriterien gibt
incident und oder hospitalisierung
bezogen für 2g und weitere schritte
haben wir schon im juli in einem bericht
des bundesministeriums geworben haben
auch dafür geworden ist im august in die
bund- länder- ergebnisse mit
hineinzunehmen es ist gut dass es jetzt
gemeinsames einheitliches vorgehen im
bund und zwischen bund und ländern dafür
gibt jetzt ist es wichtig dass auch
konsequent umzusetzen
und vor allem auch konsequent zu
kontrollieren
dass die maßnahmen auch eingehalten
werden ein zweites thema ansprechen dass
die schwierige situation deutlich macht
dass gestern auch eine rolle gespielt
hat sie in der öffentlichen wahrnehmung
ja jens spahn schlägt ihr massiv alarm
sagt es ist 10 812 mittlerweile das
haben wir bisher noch nicht gehört und
versucht ein bisschen die schuld für die
aktuelle notlage von der auch spricht
etwas abzuschieben sagte er habe bereits
im sommer gewarnt am ende bleibt
natürlich die frage wenn auch im sommer
gewarnt wurde warum wurde denn
beispielsweise in den pflegeheimen dort
gibt es ja immer wieder auch ausbrüche
mit todesfällen nicht entsprechend
reagiert und beispielsweise die
testfläche früher
fünf zehn oder fünfzehn intensivbetten
man denkt dann 10 das klingt auch wie
viel aber durch es zehn prozent von zehn
betten offensichtlich ein bett das dann
auch der jeweiligen intensivstation noch
frei ist ein schlaganfall ein
herzinfarkt eine unvorhergesehene
situation und es wird sehr sehr
schwierig und deswegen ist eben das
verlegen und idealerweise auch das
frühzeitige verlegen von risikopatienten
wichtig warum frühzeitig wenn erst mal
jemand an der eco ist in der beatmung
ist ist natürlich auch vom aufwand her
die verlegung in ein anderes krankenhaus
oder gar in eine andere region viel viel
größer und wir kommen in eine situation
wo wir wohl auch erstmalig in größerem
umfang werden nicht nur innerhalb eines
klebl als einer region sondern
überregional in deutschland patientinnen
und patienten verlegen müssen
möglicherweise auch ins benachbarte
ausland dazu gibt es enge und länder
abstimmung jede woche ein drittes thema
das ich ansprechen möchte ist die frage
des impfens und vor allem der
auffrischimpfung das boostern wie gesagt
das ist wichtig ist es auch wichtig um
die wälle dynamik unter kontrolle zu
bekommen aber es bricht es sie eben
nicht kurzfristig das ist auch wichtig
zu sehen dass wir dort sehen ist dass
das tempo deutlich zunimmt wir haben
letztere 4 millionen impfdosen bestellt
worden sind die wir ausgeliefert haben
diese woche vier nächste woche über
sechs millionen impfdosen die
ausgeliefert werden die bestellt worden
sind von den arztpraxen von den
impfzentren von den impfenden stellen in
deutschland
eine zeit nur noch 20 die booster info
die ist ein ganz wichtiges thema denn
sparen spricht es gerade an war gestern
auf großes thema beim corona gipfel und
wenn man sich das abschlusspapier genau
durchliest dann wird man verstehen auch
hier hat die bundesregierung leider gar
nichts aus den fehlern vom letzten
winter gelernt denn jetzt sollen die
über 60 jährigen gezielt wie es heißt
angeschrieben werden gezielt
angeschrieben werden aber die große
frage bleibt
wie ist die datenbasis woher wissen
jetzt beispielsweise ärzte woher wissen
auch impfzentren wer eigentlich in
diesem land über 60 ist auf welche
datenbasis beruft man sich da das wird
wieder die ganz große herausforderung
werden um bis weihnachten ein ziel von
bis zu 25 millionen zusätzlichen
impfungen erreichen zu können
wir haben stand heute morgen 5,2
millionen auffrischimpfungen deutschland
15 prozent der über 60 jährigen haben
eine solche erhalten aber es reicht eben
noch nicht wir brauchen und das war auch
gestern wichtig in der vereinbarung von
bund und ländern ein noch größeres tempo
auch bei den auffrischimpfungen seit
letzten dienstag diesen letzten dienstag
dieser woche ist die vergütung ja durch
eine verordnung die ich gezeichnet habe
erhöht von 20 auf 28 euro für jede kurve
neun zehn impfungen am wochenende auf 36
euro für jede kurve 19 impfung um den
zusätzlichen aufwand den die arztpraxen
haben in der umstellung in den abläufen
in dem was es auch jetzt wieder auch an
nachfragen durch patientinnen und
patienten gibt abzubilden wir haben
vereinbart dass die impfzentren bis ende
mai
mindestens durch den bund finanziert
werden die länder haben darauf
hingewiesen dass wenn man personal
gewinnen will und halten will für die im
zentrum eben auch längerfristige
verträge natürlich wichtig sind deswegen
bis ende mai und ich will auch
ausdrücklich sagen dass wir stärker
werden auch jetzt eine zeitlang den
impfstoff von moderner für die booster
impfung benutzen von diesem haben wir
dann fiel auch vorrätig zudem finde ich
auch wichtig im stoff so zu nutzen dass
keiner verfällt auch das müssen wir gut
aus steuern beide impfstoffe biontech
wie moderner sind gleich gut geeignet
zur auffrischimpfung und jetzt mit dem
bei den auffrischimpfungen auch moderner
in den nächsten wochen wieder eine etwas
größere rolle spielen abschließend meine
damen und herren das war eine woche der
entscheidung seien letzten samstag
kostenlose bürger tests wieder verfügbar
am dienstag dem verordnung mit der
vergütung für die ärzte die finanzierung
der impfzentren gestern die entscheidung
im deutschen bundestag für die
rechtlichen grundlagen für das handeln
der länder und der behörden vor ort die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gestern
nachmittag heute der bundesrat nach
diesen entscheidungen geht es jetzt
darum das auch umzusetzen und zu leben
in entschlossenem staatlichen handelns
aber das ist ihnen auch an uns gerichtet
an alle bürgerinnen und bürger natürlich
auch im verantwortlichen handeln jedes
einzelnen das gilt seit 18 monaten dass
das zusammenkommen muss entschlossen
dass staatliches handeln und das handeln
jedes einzelnen im alltag
ich weiß dass viele das auch tun das
impfen ist das testen ist das
aufeinander aufpassen ich weiß aber auch
dass mindestens genauso viele ist leid
sind wir alle hatten gehofft durch die
impfung auf einen anderen winter müssen
aber in feststellen durch die delta
variante und die zu große zahl an
ungeimpften dass sie wieder in einer
schwierigen wenn nicht sogar in der
schwersten lage sind in dieser pandemie
das fällt schwer das tut weh das
frustriert aber es nützt alles nächstes
ist so und deswegen geht es darum auch
jetzt gut aufeinander aufzupassen sich
zu schützen
alltag durch masken aha regeln vor allem
aber eben auch durch impfen schützen sie
sich und andere herzlichen dank
guten tag meine damen und herren wir
haben in deutschland zurzeit 110 land
[Musik]
ja jens spahn hat also noch mal gesagt
wie frustriert er ist er spricht von der
mutmaßlich schwersten situationen
innerhalb der pandemie das würde sich
vor einigen wochen monaten noch ganz
anders an da ist offenbar auch der
minister massiv überrascht worden von
der entwicklung die er auf der einen
seite sagt er vorausgesehen hat aber auf
der anderen seite wenn man das anschaut
was bisher nicht geleistet wurde an
vorleistungen dann doch überraschend
kommt ganz klar ist und ganz klar bleibt
man merkt ihm an er ist froh wenn das
amt des gesundheitsministers künftig
nicht mehr auf seinen schultern lastet
und für den nachfolger denen es dann ja
mutmaßlich anfang dezember geben wird
ist dieser job ein höllenjob
in der höchsten stufe des kontroll
kowitz stufenkonzept ist das ist die
stufe 2 bei allen drei leitindikatoren
sind die schwellenwerte überschritten
die bundesweite sieben tage sind sie
denn es ist inzwischen bei weit über 300
die sieben tage hospitalisierung
inzidenz hat in dieser woche bundesweit
den von uns vorgeschlagenen
schwellenwert von 5 überschritten sie
liegt bei 5,3 und von allen bundesweit
betreibt waren betten und
intensivstationen sind bereits 15
prozent mit cupid 19 patienten belegt
der von uns vorgeschlagene schwellenwert
liegt bei 12 prozent das ist wie gesagt
der bundesdeutsche durchschnitt aber in
vielen regionen sind die krank oder
intensivstation natürlich tatsächlich am
anschlag die medizinische versorgung ist
dort zum teil nicht mehr gewährleistet
das kann auch bedeuten dass auch andere
patienten im zweifelsfalle neben nicht
mehr optimal versorgt werden menschen
mit schlaganfall zum beispiel bei
menschen die einen unfall hatten die
todesfälle mit komik 19 steigen wieder
rasant an wir bekommen bereits jetzt
schon an vielen tagen zwischen 200 und
300 todesfälle
übermittelt das ist die situation heute
und wir rechnen damit dass sie sich in
ganz deutschland auch weiter zuspitzt
wir müssen einfach kinder und ältere
menschen schützen wir sind leider an
einem punkt angelangt an dem wir viel
krankheit und leid gar nicht mehr
verhindern können trotzdem haben wir es
zum großen teil immer noch selbst in der
hand wie schlimm diese situation in der
zukunft noch wird und vor allem wie
lange sie noch anhält wir müssen jetzt
das ruder herumreißen wir dürfen
wirklich keine zeit verlieren das ist
wie bei einem tancredi auf eine
hafenmauer zufährt der tanker ist erst
mal in bewegung wenn wir sofort alle
kraft gegensteuern wird noch eine weile
weiter fahren und die hafenmauer
vielleicht noch seitlich rahmen er wirkt
sie aber hoffentlich nicht mehr frontal
einreißen wir alle können und müssen
jetzt gegensteuern
impfungen und die dritte impfung meine
damen und herren sind natürlich enorm
wichtig erste erkranken deutlich
seltener symptomatisch an kuwait 19 und
sie müssen auch deutlich seltener ins
krankenhaus wir haben dazu in unserem
wochenbericht er jeden donnerstag raus
kommt also gestern grafiken für die
verschiedenen altersgruppen
veröffentlicht die sehr eindrücklich
sind hier ist eine grafik da sind die 18
bis 59 jährigen und sie sehen auf der
linken seite die symptomatischen
patienten mit kurven sind infektionen
auf der rechten seite die
hospitalisierten fälle mit komik 19
infektion die gestrichelte linie meine
damen und herren die obere das sind die
ungeimpften
die untere linie sind die gesten man
sieht ja deutlich den unterschied die
impfungen wirken sehr sehr gut
also wir müssen jetzt die impflücken
schließen auch zweig ist wichtig aber in
der aktuellen situation reicht das
leider nicht mehr wir brauchen jetzt
zusätzlich eine massive kontakt
reduktion um die ausbreitung des virus
zu verlangsamen dazu gehört zb gemäß den
vorschlag vorschlägen von kontroll cupid
in stufe 2 wenn möglich zu hause bleiben
großveranstaltungen absagen personenzahl
bei kleineren veranstaltungen reduzieren
hotspots wie schlecht belüftete basen
clubs schließen dazu gehört auch dass
wir alle unsere privaten kontakte so
weit wie möglich reduzieren und wir
sollten natürlich treffen mit vielen
menschen in innenräumen vermeiden weil
das virus jahr überaus ole übertragen
wird und wenn sie sich mit risikogruppen
treffen machen sie vorher bitte
sicherheitshalber einen selbst fest auch
wenn sie geimpft oder genesen sind bitte
halten sie immer und überall an die aha
regeln also den abstand einhalten
mund nasen schutz tragen jene regeln
beachten und natürlich das lüften aber
auch wenn sie geimpft sind und auch wenn
sie zusätzlich getestet sind also auch
bei 2g veranstaltungen möglichst
zusätzlich noch vorsichtsmaßnahmen
treffen und wenn die symptome einer
akuten atemwegsinfektionen haben dann
bitte bleiben sie zu hause und
kontaktieren ihren arzt bitte lasst uns
alle diese maßnahmen zusammen mit tragen
wir schaffen sie eben nur gemeinsam
diesen tanker um im bild zu bleiben zu
bremsen ich fasse das noch mal kurz
zusammen die täglichen fallzahlen die
wir im moment sehen die dürfen wir
einfach nicht mehr hinnehmen jeden tag
infizieren sich zehntausende menschen in
unserem land davon werden jeweils einige
hundert sterben diese eimer wasser der
ist ausgeschüttet
dieses wasser kriegen wir da nicht mehr
rein das ist geschehen
warten wir bitte nicht darauf dass
jemand anderes etwas macht lassen sie
uns jeder und jeder mit unseren eigenen
entscheidungen dafür sorgen dass wir
diesen tanker bremsen gemeinsam kriegen
wir das im griff aber es erfordert
wirklich um das gemeinsame anstalt danke
ihnen herzlichen dank professor wille
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir zu fragen bitte an
unser frage regime denken eine frage
eine zusatzfrage ich habe auch schon
über zehn hier vorliegen und versuchen
wir die alle abzuarbeiten ich beginne
mit online sascha meyer von dpa frage an
herrn spahn und professor wähler bund
und länder haben schwellen für schärfere
maßnahmen
vereinbart die an die hospitalisierung
rate anknüpfen ist das wirklich ein
geeigneter früh waren um die karte auch
wenn die zahlen ja offensichtlich
mehrere tage nach laufen und nicht
tagesaktuell sind ich glaube wir müssen
es ist sind schwellenwerte wie wir es
vorher bei den instanzen bei den
infektionen ja auch schwellenwerte
hatten der vor allem auch angeben in
aller regel kommt man ja von unten an
den schwellenwert in welcher dynamik ist
wächst deswegen empfehle ich auch nicht
bis wenn man bei
2,89 ist zu warten bis 30.1 ist oder bei
5,93 als hospitalisierung sind sie denn
es ist so dass man bei 6 und insofern
geht es darum dass man sozusagen eine
größenordnung hat die auch weg von
djokovic waren etwas andere zahlen aber
dann doch eben in etwa der gleichen
größenordnung das wenn man sozusagen in
diesem bereich hinein kommt dann auch
entsprechende maßnahmen notwendig sind
und im zweifel früher als später also
ich kann jedenfalls nicht empfehlen eben
auch in dem wissen dass es ein
zeitverzug ja gibt aber wir haben
zumindest was die bundesweite aus
metallisierung since it ends angeht sie
sehen das ja auch im gestrigen
wochenbericht mittlerweile auch fast und
nennen sie das ja wie wir es bei den
instanzen hatten aus den erfahrungen der
letzten woche immer eine linie die man
auch einfach zeichnen kann weil man
einfach weiß wieviel nachmeldung sondern
größten wahrscheinlichkeit noch kommen
und das können die länder ja auch wenn
man das vorher seht ihr die dynamik
weiter geht also kurzum das sind
wichtige schwellenwerte aber eben nicht
stellenwert
in dem wissen dass es auch zeitverzug in
der meldung gibt wo man nur erst handeln
sollte wenn man drüber liegt sondern
zweifel sich vorher schon die dynamik
anschaut und im zweifel auch
dann eben nicht auf den letzten wert
noch wartet
ja ich verstehe das auch so sie können
sich sicher sein dass alle menschen die
sich mit dieser pandemie wirklich
ernsthaft fachlich beschäftigen und
diese werte erhalten bzw errechnen
monitoren dass die natürlich auch die
anderen werte mit dem kopf haben und ich
sehe das natürlich auch so dass man
nicht bis zum letzten moment wartet
sondern dass dies wirklich die
allerletzte handlungsoption ist und so
verstehe ich das und ich weiß dass in
allen bundesländern diejenigen die dort
arbeiten in den gesundheitsämtern als
auch natürlich die solchen referent der
ländern diejenigen die dafür zuständig
sind wie diese daten erfasst werden dass
sie natürlich schon bevor die ampel
wirklich knallrot ist warnungen geben
sie glauben doch nicht ernsthaft dass
irgendein solchen reform dem land nicht
auf die instanzen schauen natürlich sind
die instanzen auch wichtig und die its
belastet und ich kann noch mal kurz
sagen es gibt drei wichtige faktoren das
eine die instanzen die reflektieren die
infektions dynamik das ist der früheste
die zweite sind die hospitalisierung
gehen für die reflektieren das
krankheitsgeschehen die schwere des
krankheitsgeschehens dritte dann ist die
rate auf die tsg ist ein indikator für
die belastung des gesundheitssystems und
natürlich haben die leute das alles im
blick